so hello and thanks for joining us here
at the BAFTA games masterclass
my name is Adele cutting I'll be hosting
this evening I'm an audio director and
run the games out audio outsourcing
company sound cuts today I'll be talking
to the amazingly talented and multi
award-winning Gareth Coker on the art of
storytelling through music but first of
all we'd like to thank the BAFTA Games
official partners who are Activision
Blizzard EA play fusion Tencent Ubisoft
and Sega for they're supporting us being
able to put on events like this around
the UK so BAFTA produces a number of
games events around the year these
include both public and private member
events for more details on joining BAFTA
as a full member or any of the other
BAFTA initiatives please visit BAFTA org
so now without further ado mr. Garrett
Coker
[Applause]
so thank you very much for coming this
evening
thank you obviously everybody wants to
talk about Ori because it was such a
roaring success I guess so
so I'll start off by asking you how did
you and Moon Studios get in contact with
each other in the first place a random
email back in the depths of time what
appears in out the depths of time so I
was a member of a website called Mon to
D be calm and I had a profile there and
I was scoring some some really small
projects and randomly the director of
Ori Thomas Marla he found me on the
website found a couple of pieces of
music that he'd liked of mine and he
just contacted me out of the blue said I
have a prototype that I think is really
cool
I know I would be interested in having
you write some music for it if he do the
prototype and I like the music and we're
picked up by a publisher you can score
the rest of the game and about five to
six months later Microsoft picked up the
game and the rest is history was there a
specific track that they liked yes there
was it was from a really obscure student
film that I did at the University of
Southern California but the student that
student film in question was set in a
forest and I think that was kind of what
what got the the juices rolling with
them do you want to play well I'm going
to go over here quickly
uh-oh now I can't find the folder
[Music]
[Music]
and that's literate also there's 50
seconds of music is basically what got
me the hora gig brilliant so it doesn't
always work out like that so when they
first got in contact with you did they
tell you much about the storyline when
you did how much of the storyline did
you know before you wrote your pitch I
what I did know that actually no I
didn't know the story all I got given
for the for the pitch was four different
playable levels and they just said we
need we need gameplay music for these
four different environments so what they
what they were trying to show in the
pitch was a range of colors environments
and diversity in sound and in visuals
the gameplay was a typical platformer
with some of the unique abilities that
you that you have in Ori but in terms of
the story it Thomas the director had it
in his head but he I don't think he
wanted to reveal it to anyone in case it
got you know nicked or something but he
he never told me the story while we were
doing the prototype it was just it was
only until we got the pitch that I
actually knew the plot for the game okay
because I've read quite a lot about the
fact that they were heavily inspired by
The Lion King and the Iron Giant yes you
told about that he did what what what
Thomas liked he gives us a lot of lists
of things to to watch and and consume he
basically any Disney film where a cuddly
character dies is is something that we
were encouraged to watch so yes Lion
King Bambi
my enjoyment was what the Disney films
are very good at is is making bringing
out really really deep emotions in
something in in visuals that are
actually quite simple to look at like an
you cry yes so you want a pitch you
started working it how much information
did they give you so you knew
you were told the storyline at this
point yeah but did they give you any
ideas in terms of a music brief
directions number of cues how much was
left to you and how much was dictated
this was probably one of the the best
things about working on the project I
had total despite my complete lack of
experience they had they gave me total
creative freedom they had maybe a couple
of tracks like one from Avatar and one
from from Moneyball of all films but
Moneyball has a great soundtrack which
is it's it's very melancholy it works
really well for the film and in strange
way this one cue worked really well for
Ori but really I listened to them I'm
like I kind of get it and then we threw
them out pretty quickly so in terms of
tone I had complete freedom in terms
coming up with a theme complete freedom
they didn't really care as long as they
felt that it worked and one of the
luxuries I had was to be able to spend a
really long time with the game so I was
familiar with the game when there was no
art in the game when when Ori was a
square little geometric geometric shape
and all of the levels were just made up
of squares and triangles so I got a feel
for how the game felt in the hands of
the player very early on and it was only
until the arts came in that like the
music really started to to get written
at a very fast pace but having the full
access to the game every single build
every single piece of concept every
single thing that gets uploaded to
Dropbox even the failed experiments and
tests like getting to see them and
seeing what someone was trying to do all
of that helped inform my own direction
of the music as having access to
everyone else's work helped kind of
clarify in my head what I wanted to do
and one thing that also really helped
with from Moon Studios is that they
encouraged not just me but everyone on
the team
fail you I felt like even and this was
very really helpful because I was
relatively new having a forum in which I
could try stuff and it's okay to get it
wrong and not be you not feel like
you're going to lose your job or get
reprimanded or anything like that I was
able to try stuff try it out in-game and
if it doesn't work okay I just start
again so that the worst problem I ever
had on an Ori was oh I have to write
more music big deal so they always just
said keep plugging at it until you got
it right it's a highly highly iterative
approach a lot of game development is
like that but there was an encouragement
to experiment and think outside the box
as opposed to going for the safe
solution did you get a lot of feedback
how close was your working relationship
with the main producer and the project
or the sound designer did you speak with
them a lot about your music and how it's
working in game I well I test the game a
lot myself so if I'm not if I'm not
happy with it myself if it doesn't feel
good to me I'm never going to show it to
anyone anyone because if I didn't feel
that it's good how on earth can I expect
anyone here or any of the people who I'm
working with to think it's good so I
never submitted something it's what I
was happy with until I was getting until
I was feeling something from the game
but then when I did usually I'd only get
feedback if it didn't work if if it if
it gets the weight the way it works we
upload it into the game and then people
kind of play it and live with it and if
if nothing comes back that means it's
really good yes
now you'll never get told you'll never
get told when it's when it's really good
you only get told when it sucks so did
they understand music though could could
the producer talk to you on a technical
level about music in terms of using
musical terminology yeah music he either
it's kind of there's a technical
director and there's creative director
Thomas is the creative director and
gennady's kind of the technical director
gennady communicates in in musical terms
because he's pretty capable saxophone
player and he's quite good at music
thomas is literally
can't communicate in musical terms at
all but it can communicate emotions and
feelings it's a kind of between the two
of them I kind of had the best of both
worlds
I always lean to the emotional side of
things it's much easier to figure out
what's wrong and what's right when
emotions are being communicated so and
yeah if the emotion was being nailed
Thomas would have nothing to say so it's
it's very rare for him to say something
is good if there's something if he said
something is good then it actually means
it's a masterpiece and it's the greatest
thing ever written so audio directors
the way they work with a music brief is
they'll actually read the story they'll
see their key characters how the
relationships develop and so like work
out from that a list of cues that are
needed for the game how how do you work
I think for me the first thing I start
with is looking for the character theme
but also how it relates to the overall
story now we're fortunate and then we
had the story kind of written at least
the the main pillars of the story and
you know the there's really only one
main character in the game so that
character needs a strong main theme and
I went through several several different
versions of the the main theme and it
wasn't even me that actually found the
main theme it was in a folder of piano
experiments and someone else on the team
I can't remember who it was pointed out
that like hey this this track like
random track 4 in piano experiments in
the audio folder is kind of cool
maybe you should develop it into the
main theme and then I actually expanded
the sketch into something like a fully
fledged piece of music and I was like
there it is and from that though the
rest of the score was kind of born in
terms of a cue list I kind of just went
through the game based on which areas of
artwork had been finished first so
fortunately because the work because of
the way the game was developed
everything was finished kind of in order
so for example our 8th
rido was the opening 15 minutes of the
games it was kind of cool to have the
opening 15 minutes kind of set up and
scored and then just like different
parts of the game different levels got
filled in and I was able to kind of jump
on one level at a time as soon as the
artwork got finished then it was time
for music and sound to go in and we did
our stuff their music and set once we'd
finished music and sound for one level
then art had finished on an another
level so we were kind of always chasing
ours yeah tag-teaming yeah it was a
really nice way to work the one
exception it's with the cutscenes where
we I was given the storyboards and the
storyboards had the most basic amount of
information in it but what was cool
about that is I was given the
storyboards and they said right piece of
music that kind of fits this scene times
the timing but if you want we can if you
feel like a Pete the music needs to be
extended in certain places so you can do
a better build or you need to do a
something that will help them use become
more emotional will totally tweak the
animation based around your music that's
very very uncommon I think normally the
composer is given the scene and you will
score the scene based on our timings and
don't mess with it
but I was we kind of did it in Reverse
for for Ori
which was really nice for me because I
wasn't bound to timings I could make a
piece of music that I felt abdun flowed
really well we were also also by doing
this we were able to try lots of
different solutions for the same scene
instead of kind of being informed by the
visual zone makes it more musical yes I
think you do so there's two scenes we'll
need to switch to the two my computer
for this there we go so this is two
approaches for a cutscene that we did
it's a key cutscene in the game where
the antagonist is introduced to the
player for the first time you'll also
see how basic the art is in early game
development
[Music]
square in the middle is Horry
[Music]
okay so that's that's one approach that
I tried and the feedback I got was like
okay this this works but it was way way
way too dark and it's like this is the
evil owl and for those of you how many
of you have played the game by the way
it's very quick raised pants okay so
those of you have played the game know
that the antagonist is not it's not
black and white
it's not it's not she's not super super
dark and evil so here's the alternate
approach
[Music]
tonally that's slightly different and
that's kind of what we ended up going
for we wanted a little bit more mystery
and then the final version which I'm
about to show is basically the version
two but with tweets timing based on what
I based on a few little extra things
that I wanted in in the music
[Music]
okay so watching that and being a sound
designer yes I have towards the question
how did you and the sound designer work
together how did you when scoring a
piece like that a cutscene how did you
understand designer decide who was going
to be in charge at which moment what was
going to shine through the music or the
sound effects
I mean in that scene it sounds like the
music's kind of contrived so but there
is one part that's noticeable where I
drop out so I mean it's the introduction
of the antagonist it's the first time
the player comes face-to-face and it's
it's a pretty epic shot visually yeah
it's it's probably one of the iconic
shots in the game and they've they
really wanted to be like the this would
be like the oh my goodness moment but
it's kind of set up with the you know
with the storm at the beginning and so
that's what the music is fairly soft
until it's clear that they're a serious
danger so Andy and I we Andy's the sound
designer and we just kind of have had a
telepathic communication throughout
throughout the process I still don't
know how that happened because we've
never met in person until the game was
actually finished but the one thing that
we did talk about throughout the game is
giving space for especially big punchy
sound effects to shine so in that in in
in that video there's just a little part
where the owl lands and you know if I go
big on the music there he doesn't have
any room to do the big booming sound
thing so it's like okay well I can do a
big chord and I can just drop it out
have the owl land and then the music
then the out then the owl is moving
again and then it kind of makes sense to
have the music kind of push things
forward but with I feel like working
with any sound designer there's always a
push-pull and an ebb and a flow there
was never
music should dominate this scene and
sound should just take a backseat it's
we were always trying to get into the
fine details of things where music can
shine for a couple of seconds and then
sound can take over just having an into
play between the two did you share
work-in-progress like your work in
progress music for cutscenes and did he
send over is his working progress
sound effects track I think we worked we
kind of worked in alternates basically
so I usually be could because the
cutscenes were time to music music was
kind of the first thing that ended up
getting done but I would the first time
I did the music I kind of wrote thinking
about what Andy would do for the sound
effects I was like well the Owls landing
there's probably going to be a sound
effect here so it would make sense to
stay out of the way and of course that's
kind of what he did but sometimes
there's a there's a scene later on in
the game where it's very sound effects
driven and my music is informed by what
Andy does in the sound effects so it's
really we would just take each scene of
the game on a case-by-case basis and see
what the scene actually needs in terms
of music and sound sounds only that's
big take from me so yeah so we've talked
about character themes you had an Ori
theme did you use this in variation
through the game yeah the Ori theme is
almost in every environment in the game
it is about nine different environments
in the game and it's used pretty much
everywhere in some shape or form it's
not obvious in some parts but it's it's
hinted at throughout where we play the
or a theme in full is when or is making
a big impact on the world and on in the
environment otherwise it's it's very
subtle and kind of hidden but you know
the game is called Ori you were playing
as Ori the whole time and I just kind of
want to wanted to reinforce the theme
throughout the game so when you do hear
it in full it kind of feels like a hero
a moment and and a reward or mana reward
yes exactly so did you have any other
theme attic material in there we've
talked about character themes so yeah in
the prologue there are some additional
characters in the prologue notably Naru
orys adopted mother and and she does
have a theme but because she's absent
most of the game we don't really get
years except we doing the definitive
edition by the way which has a little
expansion where you can get in a ruse
back story but I kind of use that theme
occasionally when we're dealing with
anything to do with to do to do with
loss in the game so for example in in
the forlorn ruins which is where the
character goo mows gloom oh is this
really weird spider II creature you'll
see another thing I'm about to show yes
and yeah his his species has basically
all being killed off and that's that's
another place where I kind of reuse
narrows theme to to show to show loss
but really we kind of stick to one theme
it's the one thing that apparently
people were bothered about there is only
one theme in the game but it's it's it's
it's a one character game for me so I
chose to differentiate the music by
having radically different sounds for
each environment so even though the
music has an orchestra throughout the
game the music in each environment
should feel very different the orchestra
is the glue that holds all of that all
of the esoteric sounds together but each
environment you should be able to listen
to and think oh that's the ginzu tree oh
that's the forlorn ruins are that's
Mount Horeb and it should it should be
sonically identifiable immediately based
on the instruments I've chosen so that's
how I chose to change things that's the
way you can have the same theme
throughout you can change not only the
melody slightly but also the
instrumentation yes there's there's one
part of the game I want to show one
thing that I've always felt strongly
about is having composers play play the
games that they work on and this scene
in particular it's about six or seven
pieces of music which should all feel
like one what can sometimes happen is
you get a spreadsheet of music from the
audio director and it's just
like a bunch of music tracks that you
have to write and you can end up writing
them in a vacuum
now with this sequence it's it's it if I
hadn't tested it I don't think it would
have felt as continuous as as it does
and I tested the scene like crazy this
the scene I'm about to show it's it's
infamous for anyone who's played the
game everyone's giggling already because
I think they know what it's going to be
but this scene we tested over and over
again and this this scene was kind of
the first time that we knew exactly what
the game was because it has the basic
gameplay has exaggerated like heightened
gameplay and has a cutscene and it has
the the full tension and release all in
about four minutes if I do it right
awesome
[Music]
okay
okay so I don't have time to clean the
corruption on both sides so I'm just
gonna cheat a little bit and
fast-forward so this music that's
playing in the background right now it's
it's super super ambient because this is
a super mystical part of the game you're
in a magical tree where there's all this
glowing pink stuff it's completely it's
completely off the wall and it's unlike
anything there's been seen in the game
before and what's about to happen is
we're about to heal the tree from the
corruption that has been blighting it
and this sets off a series of events
that hopefully should all be seamless
[Music]
[Music]
so right now the water is filling up and
Ori has to escape
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so yeah that's that's that little
sequence awesome
so the reason why I brought that scene
up it's it's yes it's impressive to show
at a thing like this but it's it's that
there's the the ambient music at the
beginning then there's a stinger that
plays before that chase sequence then
there's the chase sequence music itself
then the cutscene on top of the ginzu
tree where the owl face is off that's
another piece of music that transitions
into the fall which is the fifth piece
of music and then finally Ori is at the
bottom in the area that is clean and
that's the sixth and final piece of
music and that all should feel
reasonably continuous especially the
last piece was where I was like okay
we've we've kind of got something
special here because that's the
resolution of everything that's happened
for if we'd had another intense gameplay
moment there would have been too much
for the player the player kind of needs
a reward to soak in to soak in
everything that's just happened it's
kind of the adrenaline is still going to
be flowing especially if it's the first
time you've played the game that's
that's the first moment of the game
where all your skills as a player up
until that point are truly truly tested
and you kind of need to let off steam
for a bit and it's incredibly satisfying
to let off steam because it's also the
first time you can swim in the game so
you've kind of got your mini Finding
Nemo moments and it's it's really
satisfying to swim because every time
you go in the water before that moment
it takes off one of your lake health
points which is very irritating so now
you can actually enjoy swimming and Ori
makes a cute swimming sound when he keep
breath sound me comes out to breathe so
that whole ending is kind of like a mini
resolution I don't think I would have
written the swamp music like that if I
hadn't understood the context fully and
having played it myself to understand
what the player was feeling before yes
exactly I think to me when I watched
that was what I find most impressive is
how seamless it seems it
seems through-composed and in fact
there's so many cues that just
seamlessly go between each other I think
that's what's to me I found that really
really really interesting so how how is
that integrated did you have W wise some
fancy nothing fancy it's hard coded into
unity there is no I'm hearing gasps from
the audience there is no there is no
audio middleware in in Horry there's all
kinds of reasons for that but we were
able to make it work through smoke and
mirrors largely I mean when I i don't do
the implementation myself but i specify
exactly what I want so someone on the
programming team can go and code it for
me any parameters you can treat so you a
lot basically basically the only
parameters I'm allowed to tweak when
things fade in fade out and the amount
of time it takes for another cue to be
triggered which is just they're all
number amounts which are very easy for
me to tweak but in terms of the actual
code no they they make an interface
basically an idiot-proof interface that
I can tweak all those transitions where
they cross fades or where they actually
done on beats of the music they went on
a beats to music they're just done
they're just done
yep just going on really short
crossfades yeah it helps when things are
in the same key obviously but I use so
it's most of that music is in B minor
but when you wake up in a swamp you're
in C major so I used the non sorry I
used the linear music so the cutscene
music that's when I can move to change
key to make it feel different because B
minor to C major is a very unnatural
transition it doesn't doesn't work if
you put them side by side you need time
to progress through to modulate but I'm
able to do that because I had a cutscene
in which I can do whatever I want yeah
yeah it's a natural all of the game play
music never modulates cuz it's just too
too dangerous to modulate especially in
a scene like that so that's that's how I
don't get trapped by staying in the same
place and there's lots of moments like
that in the game there's lots of many
cutscenes they're like 20 seconds that
allow me to kind of change direction a
little
which is very helpful and sometimes I
even asked for those look can we have a
moment where the control is taken away
for the place yeah any any time when
there's a stinger or something that's
like an opportunity to really change
things up or even just a big sound
effect you know if if if a wall
collapses obviously we're gonna hear the
wall it's going to be a really big sound
effect we can change the music in a
subtle way here without anyone hearing
the transition that's we use sound
effects a lot to hide any of the dodgy
transitions because with no with no
middleware there are some there are some
cracks that will appear very useful for
composers who don't write nice
transitions like me but I remember even
at the ending of the game I was like I
need a transition here can we just like
have a gust of wind or something which
no one really is gonna notice so just
just little things like that can make it
seem more polished I always feel like
game development in general is the art
of how well you can pull off smoke and
mirrors to hide the hide the cracks
there's just so many cracks that you're
trying to patch up yeah there's quite a
lot of that is what we probably say is
horizontal interactivity so using chunks
and adding them together to help make it
interactive where is there anywhere in
this game that you use sort like
vertical interactivity sort of like
changing between stems we did try it but
we ended up scrapping it because it felt
gimmicky that with the you're in and out
of certain game states so quickly that
it did just it just didn't really feel
right so when you're playing the game
you have the option to - to fight
monsters and monsters appear fairly
frequently in the game but they're also
very easy to kill so you don't end up
being in combat for a very long time and
also the sound effects are really strong
anyway they do a great job of telling
you you are fighting something and the
monster sound effects are quite
exaggerated they also do a great job of
telling you you're in danger if you have
the muse
also doing that it feels it can feel
like overkill and for the gameplay music
we we just I just ended up taking a
backseat and an D sound effects really
the percussion section of the music
they're very punchy and strong but that
tells the player all they need to know
but here's one other thing about the
game play music and why we didn't really
do the layered thing we didn't actually
want to communicate to the player that
killing everything is necessary killing
everything in Oriya is very satisfying
so you can just mash ax and a bunch of
fancy lights appear and and it looks and
feels great but actually we only play
combat music when you have to defeat
something to progress it's a subtle
thing that not many people have picked
up on which is fine because it is a
platformer and especially once you get
the bash ability in the game which is
the ability to to change direction off
either projectiles or monsters you don't
need to kill anything in the game
because you can just you can just you
can just redirect yourself off a
projectile remonster anytime someone
shoots or something that you just like
oh I'm gonna press triangle and see it
off you go so you just you just don't
need to fight things in the game which
is why we don't have the vertical
layered music we did also think about it
in that chase sequence but once we had
the melody in there I'm like item I
don't want to mess with this because
this is already already working really
well as is so we did try it but it just
didn't end up making making the cut who
knows we might try it in the second game
if there's an appropriate place for it
yeah we'll do it but if it's not
appropriate I won't ever do
interactivity just for the sake of
putting it in so obviously it was all an
orchestral recording yes I have to ask
because it's an indie game I've worked
with several composers and indie titles
where we haven't had the budget to
record live live orchestra yep but the
composers themselves have said you know
what I really want live instruments so
they've actually footed the bill
themselves so on this game was this
something that you talked about in
advance did you always plan to use
orchestra and did they give you the
budget or was it out your own pocket we
planned we plan to use the orchestra
from the beginning but my goodness like
we we really pushed the Nashville
musicians in terms of value for money
like an average so we had we had 12
hours of recording time the score is
about 140 minutes long so to be
recording more than 12 minutes of music
per hour is the pretty it's a pretty
relentless place just just for reference
a good pace is about 6 does a good fast
pace assist 8 minutes to music per hour
so we were asking them to do 12 but
needs must you know you just find a
scene music that's take 2 you know it's
I'm like well it's done let's move on
because we kind of had to but it was it
was planned from the very beginning that
we would do a live recording and it's
still amazing to me that they kind of
gave me that kind of level of trust
despite my lack of experience at the
time ended up being a great decision
because it did I still remember what
I've listened to the the mock-ups and
I'm like I'm glad I'm glad we did it
because it does it really does make a
difference especially in a game like
this which is dealing with you know
train train to convey emotions
throughout the game the game experience
sorry I'm really glad that we did it
especially on the studio's first title
yeah do you have a team of people you
work with you have a go-to Orchestrator
go to conductor go to engineer for these
things well here's the funny thing about
this is because we because we spend all
the money on the orchestra we didn't
really have money for orchestration or
all the music preparation so I actually
did all of that myself but I know regret
it I did not get any sleep but I do have
two core team members Alex Alex rode who
is my conductor man Zach lemon who's
kind of he's now he didn't have his dog
straighten for me by the time he's it's
kind of mid second pair of ears cause he
hears things the same way as I do and
those who have been with me on
everything
recording since we also went to school
together at the University of Southern
California so we've known each other for
nine years and it's kind of cool that
we've you know we've been able to work
together on everything since it's it's
much easier to work with your friends
and one thing I've noticed that the the
orchestra can picks up on the good
chemistry between us and when the
orchestra knows that we're having a good
time they end up having a good time too
which means they end up playing they yet
there's just like they end up giving a
little bit extra for you and that also
came across in the recordings for this
so you don't conduct it
I don't conduct because a lot of my
music has pre-recorded elements it's not
all orchestra in the room it's Orchestra
in the room combined with a bunch of
stuff there's a lot of sense work in
nori which is kind of not really at the
forefront but it's there and I kind of
need to hear the the final result plus
Alex my conductor is is absolutely
brilliant and when I'm figuring out what
to do next he's telling another 10 jokes
to the orchestra because that's what
he's really good at so he keeps the
players engaged while I'm trying to
figure out what to do next
he's I'm kind of the bad cop and he's
the good cop of musicianship there was
to be my first when when I told
Microsoft and moon that I was going to
Nashville of course the natural reaction
is why are you recording our emotional
fantasy score in Nashville the city of
banjos and Country Music but for
anything is what most people don't know
that Nashville Symphony Orchestra is won
a grammy for best classical recording in
the past and the level of musicianship
it's not just country music in Nashville
they're recording Christian rock they're
recording orchestral albums they're
recording rock music pop music so that
all the players are capable of playing
in literally any style that you put in
front of them so having a school like
aurilla is really nothing new to them
because they are really insight readers
they take one is is usable and take two
is really really really excellent so
yeah it definitely was a fast pace and
we were strapped for time but we meet
evidently got it all finished
but I would never work in that place
again
so have you I've got to ask the question
have you ever recorded in any of the
London studios yes last year I recorded
Ark survival evolved at Abbey Road
Studios and that was with a 93 piece
Orchestra which is by far the biggest
group I've ever worked with I mean it's
an appropriate sized Orchestra for a
game about dinosaurs
it's it's it's beyond epic and and if
anyone who's played the game knows that
it is it gets super ridiculous by the
time you get to the late levels you have
you have Ironman level powers your
dinosaurs can can can shoot lasers from
their eyes of that 1993 piece fifty
strings triple woodwind the brass
section was four trumpets six French
horns one tennis ROM bone two bass
trombones a contrabass trombone which is
a real luxury one sandbar so one tuba
and for percussionists I think that
makes 93 Wow it's so to compare that
next to Ori what was the Ori set up like
so 75% of the score for Ori is done with
22 strings
flute oboe and clarinet and piano and
the remaining 20% is done with 30
strings 4 horns 3 trombones and double
woodwind so that it's a large section is
about 50 players and the the regular
section is 25 so which work for the game
I think actually like the chamber sized
orchestra really worked for kind of the
intimate intimate setting there's
something we have a big string section
some of the intimacy gets lost because
it's this big massive sound when you
have 22 players in the string section
you can kind of really hear the rosin on
the bow when when a violinist is playing
as opposed to 50 you're not going to
hear that you're not going to hear the
real detail yeah but that real detail
kind of brings you a little bit closer
to the characters at least that's what
it sounded like to me
yeah I said I'm just gonna pop to a
couple of people sent me questions just
before the event so that I think we
might have answered a couple of them
there we go this one's from Michael
leaning as Santa's owner shotgun mic
audio as a sound designer who works on
different kinds of visual media
virtually all of them with music I
always try to take into consideration
what's going on in the music when
designing assets of soundscapes
what do you do as a composer when
considering the sounds that will play
alongside your school yeah I mean it's
one of the I think I'm lucky and I have
very easy access to the sound designers
who I work with I kind of make a point
of reaching out to them wherever
wherever possible and if I'm able to
talk to them about the scene beforehand
and then then I'll discuss discuss what
it's needed but if I'm not able to get a
hold of them I'm just gonna look at the
scene myself and you know turn any music
off and think what are the big sound
effects moments here that I might have
to possibly write around it's quite easy
to write around a sound effects
once you've once you're able to plan for
it and set everything up in terms of the
timing and getting the right tempo for
the music so it just it just requires a
thought process but I'm always thinking
about what is the sound doing here and
in the case of aurilla good example is
with sound effects being the percussion
once I'd established that I'm like why
don't need to use any percussion
instruments before that's one section of
the orchestra wiped out I don't even
need to worry about it which you know
made my life a little bit easier
although it obviously didn't have none
or E yeah but on other titles that
you've worked on have you ever handed
your music over to somebody else to
implement yes so on the unspoken which
is a virtual-reality title by Insomniac
Games it's it's it's a game where you
are a wizard and you can cast magic
spells in VR with your hands which is
really really awesome it's kind of like
Mortal Kombat but for wizards so yeah
for that game I was asked to write
within a specific system specific music
system that the the
audio lead her designed and we didn't
know if it would work but it looked like
it would work and he just said we need
we need an ambient cue we need a regular
bounce or cue we need an escalated
bounce or Q and we need transitions to
go from each age ambient from ambient to
battle from battle to escalate and then
there's a boss cue as well and it was
that WI yes that was w wise but I never
had any any contact with the W wise
middleware I literally just handed over
the audio files made sure that they
looped correctly and handed them over
and they would come back to me and I
would listen to enemy okay that's great
that's the way I prefer to work so
obviously you're heavily involved with
Ori yeah this one obviously for the
implementation so not so but did you
still get really involved in actually
playing the game and giving feedback
because she said that as you played Ori
you you might change the keys because
you actually heard it yep
with with the unspoken because because
it was an oculus touch twice it was a
launch title of oculus touch there's
security issues about about getting
access to Twitter but I live in LA and
insomniac games are in LA - so I was
just able to go over there and play the
game myself and later on they would just
send tons and tons and tons of video so
anyone who's working in games as a
composer now if you if for whatever
reason you can't play the game and there
are valid security reasons for not being
able to get hold of the build of the
game get them to send a video or ask to
go to the studio to play the game either
one or the other because it's it's
immensely helpful we did do a
single-player expansion for the unspoken
and they literally just recorded the
entire game from start to finish four
hours of it and I was like it felt like
scoring a movie to be honest and it was
great fun it was just scoring a movie
kind of in chunks and making sure the
correct parts looped and they had all of
the cues laid out for me for which parts
needed to be looped and which parts
needs to be transitions so it was really
really easy to work with but it's it's
just kind of nice
when he can hand stuff over and it's
implemented so that was a VR title yes
did that change the way you thought
about them how the music was going to be
in the game
did it change the way you thought you
were going to mix the music or where you
thought I mean was it up to you if the
music was just stereo at the front
whether it was all around you I think
the one thing it was interesting because
we the multiplayer component of the game
came out at the end of 2016 the single
player component game came out of 2017
and there was definitely a definite
progression in the music based on what I
learned from the first time around so
one thing I found about sound in the
multiplayer game it's it's very
transient heavy there's a lot of there's
a lot of high frequency punchy sounds
and I was and I recorded a live drum kit
for the further multiplayer and it
sounds awesome but I realized pretty
quickly that I had to like cut off all
of the high end stuff from the from the
drum kit and so for the single player
there's hardly any percussion there's
certainly not on the high and there's no
cymbals there's no there's no clicky
percussion there's a lot of bass kicks
but they don't really get in the way as
much but it was one of those things
where I learned a lot just from just
from having experienced the game and
having and now having another listening
just just from listening to it but I I
think I would not have expected the
sound to be quite as detailed because
because it is coming from you in all
directions the game it makes to be
surround I wouldn't it feels like it's a
surround game just because you can
teleport anywhere on the on the on the
battlefield by one of the main mechanics
of the game is you can teleport so you
if I'm here right now I can just use the
teleport spell to be right behind you
and then cast a spell from behind you so
obviously you can hear that whereas in a
game like Mortal Kombat it's kind of
like left right so you kind of know
where things are going to occur on
staring field but with VI you haven't
you don't you have a lot more options
and I would have probably made the music
less busy on a second go-around it's not
it still works but in the single-player
I'm able to rectify that by making the
music a little bit less busy and
the sound effects still have their time
to shine but the music still has the
driving momentum it just it just felt
like because the the sound field was
bigger that there was a lot more going
on because you've worked on survival yes
and that is that was early access wasn't
there yes so how was that for you
because obviously people could give you
feedback on your own music oh boy so
yeah my favorite story with that is with
with the main theme so the main theme
for arc was literally the first piece of
music that I wrote for the game and it
ended up staying in it didn't even get
to a version - it's extremely rare for a
version one to get approved especially
for something as important as the main
theme but they ended up putting it in
the trailer and it's this rousing piece
of music that is a call to action and
it's and it's tied up with a montage of
dinosaurs and humans doing all kinds of
crazy things
it is absolutely wild and it got a lot
of people interested in the game and I
dared to tweak the main theme and I did
but tweaking I mean like subtle EQ
things and and production techniques
that I did not think the public would
notice and eventually we recorded the
theme with a with the orchestra Abbey
Road and I remember when we put it in as
an update and it's literally the same
notes as the very first version I did
not change a thing
and quotes they've ruined the music and
I'm like no I haven't really but it's
really just an adjustment period
the people who've been playing the game
and living with it for at that point two
years become so used to hearing the main
theme in a certain format and just they
become attached to it and then there's a
nostalgic element if you start screwing
with people's memories you weren't
tempted to hook it out and go public no
I mean we left it in there but it was
kind of tempting for me to like leave an
option where you like legacy music like
so if you if you want to hear the old
you have that option but the people that
people adapted to people it's it's like
when whenever Facebook or the BBC do a
web site revamp everyone is really
annoyed by it because they have to find
you have to everything is in a slightly
different place but then we all adapt
because it's human nature and then
everything's fine
but I remember the heat the heat after
after we changed and it wasn't just the
main theme it was it was all the combat
means they got all got it all got
re-recorded yeah the heat was quite
astonishing it was a very unique thing
for me because it's not unusual for a
director to fall in love with a piece of
temp music but in this case my music is
the temp music and I want to replace it
yeah but I'm not allowed to it was it
was there was that was a new experience
for me that I've never had in games
before and I think I think just now it's
just one of those things that I would
accept moving forward you know that
there's there's always going to be an
adjustment period and an early access
title but without the early access we
wouldn't have been able to record at
Abbey Road in the first place because I
sold a lot of units which allowed us to
do that big recording so it's you've you
kind of take the rough with the smooth I
don't know if you want to play a bit yes
and I'm not gonna play the original
thing that I wrote you're gonna you're
gonna get the version that I like okay
so this is the this is the main theme
[Music]
nice quiet subtle okay I've just got one
more question which I just want to ask
because they put it in before the event
I feel I need to say it
so this is from Elliot Daniels a
composer at Penn Works media he says is
your approach to storytelling for
videogames different to how you might
approach storytelling in film and what
are those differences if any I mean the
obvious main point to start with is with
with film you're going from A to B and
there's there's a fix there's a fixed
way you're gonna do it's gonna be the
same whenever you watch a film it's the
same way every time whenever you're
playing any narrative game it's going to
be slightly different and that's that's
what you've got to take into
consideration whenever doing a game as
for how I approach it I still feel like
I approach it with the same mindset that
I have doing a film I want to get I want
to get the key dramatic and emotional
moments absolutely right with the parts
where you're dealing with looping music
that's where that's the big difference
between you'll never have looping music
so that's the part where it really is
very different that's where you've got
to keep the player immersed and you've
got to keep them engaged in the world
you've got to write a piece of music
which is which they can listen to for
five to ten minutes
potentially but doesn't annoy them but
also does enough to keep them engaged in
the world and that is that for me is the
most fun challenge of game music is how
do you keep the player immersed for long
periods of time but also but also not
annoy the hell out of them that's the
biggest challenge to see where as a film
you're never going to run into that
problem because you know you're never
going to have to loop music so that that
there's not really a different approach
it's more just like there's different
problems to solve
also your musics always going to be
there in in a film your music it's baked
in whereas in the game people can turn
off your music as well yes you've got to
keep them interested yes I'll just fade
that yes
exactly yeah it's yeah it's funny like
when you know that we every game has to
have the music slider and I'm just like
don't touch it but but you've got it
sits on the composer to make sure that
they don't even consider reaching for
that music slider and that that means
not you know that means composing
something that's not annoying although
what's funny is you know that that Ark
theme it's really it's kind of
obnoxiously loud and it's the first
thing you hear on on the main menu and
it's it's kind of a running gag now
about how loud the music is on the main
menu but people never change the volume
slider because also is the call to
action so it's yeah it gets them in the
mood exactly I feel like gay music has
to get you it has to get you in the mood
and ready to play you have to be it has
to get you into that zone where you're
where you're ready to play a game if I
feel like when I'm really immersed in a
game there's like nothing that can take
me out of it
in the case of Oreo boy one of the one
of the best decisions we made was to
have no loading screens and I've seen
people play the game for the first time
that my I hate platformers I don't want
to play this platform of suck and I just
shut up here's the control and and then
they play for like three and a half
hours because they don't know where to
stop you have to willingly want to stop
which means pressing start and finding
the pause many and that's the only time
when the music actually actually stops
playing and so that means we've done a
good job with keeping the player engaged
and immerse but that is a really really
that's one of the most enjoyable
challenges for me is like how look it
was finding like a personal chance how
long can I keep the player in this game
so that they don't even have to go and
eat some questions in the audience now
if anybody has one we go to that chap
over there
thank you so much for an enlightening
thing I sort of recognized the power of
music in games we want to play the
original medal of honor on PlayStation
which is great I'm just going to know in
terms of your evolution as a composer
with games what would you say is your
the biggest thing you've learnt and what
are the things that you still struggle
with when you're trying to work with the
game I'll start with what I struggle
with I'm still a control freak I do
I still do too much work myself and I
have been very slow to learn to give
work to trusted advisors with Ori
because I did everything myself and it's
kind of like it's kind of like my first
baby you know I didn't I didn't want no
one touch it but gradually I've learned
but in the case of arc it's physically
impossible for me to orchestrate like a
hundred and fifty minutes of music for
93 players and I wanted to do it myself
but I was it got to the point where I
was like why am i doing this myself why
am i doing a 15th piece of battle music
which I've already done 14 why don't I
show an Orchestrator my template for how
to get it done and they can do the
remaining tracks so the delegation is
something I still struggle with even
though even though I do have trusted
advisors and friends that would easily
step in and help me out with it
and yeah I guess the thing that I've
I've learnt the the most and I mentioned
it at the beginning I've I've become
even more willing to fail and experiment
but I've also been very lucky that I've
had developers who have allowed me to do
that if there are any developers here in
the room please encourage your your
composers and your artists and your
animators to to fail and experiment and
try to come up with something new
because you might end up with something
that you never heard before it's
something I'm now more
to do than ever before and I used to be
scared of doing that because when you
when you when you've been told that you
failed you feel like you might lose your
job and especially when you're at the
beginning of your career you that's the
last thing you actually want but but now
having done that several times it's
become easier and easier who's next
so I think you've said in the past that
you started out doing like more
electronic stuff yes and then getting
into into games you kind of ended up
with this kind of like an orchestral
yeah identity how do you feel about that
and do you feel like you've been kind of
like sent down this rabbit hole that you
well are you gonna get out of I mean I
did
I've always enjoyed doing electronic
music my score for the my score for the
unspoken is entirely electronic it's
it's basically a mix of electronic and
rock music so I did get to finally
revisit that but if you flash back to
the beginning of this talk where I
played the track that got me the or Iggy
it's not all Kestrel it's very very
ambient and it's very electron there's
it's it's it's organic
ambient music the sounds are rooted in
the real world but they're heavily
treated so I'm classically trained I
went to the Royal Academy of Music and I
went to University of Southern
California both really really good
schools for learning traditional music
but I've always had a love for
electronic music since I can't remember
when it started but there are production
techniques and electronic music the
transfer really really well over to
producing film music and vice versa so I
kind of just feel like the two worlds
intertwine for me me ending up doing all
kestrel music I mean it's just what
happened because of already like if you
know or he came out
we used an orchestra I'm probably going
to get to do more orchestral music but
that's why it was a real surprise when
insomniac games picked me to do the
unspoken I'm convinced they did a blind
audition because I think if they'd seen
they see my name next to thing they'd be
like why would why is the Ori composer
submitting something for this and they
liked the attitude that my pitch my
pitch had and so I got to do two and a
half hours of electronic rock music
which was which is really awesome so I
feel very fortunate that I haven't quite
been pigeon holed yet but if I'm going
to be pigeonholed there's worse things
to be pigeonholed then doing the kind of
music that I do further worry I do find
it interesting actually that you're
still pitching you know it's mean
because after all the awards that are we
got you know you'd assume if you didn't
know the industry that that's just like
I am Gareth co-current only if it was
that simple sadly it isn't I mean I have
I have been got I have gotten gigs
without pitching but but generally
speaking I mean I don't mind pitching
it's it's it's fine it's yeah kind of it
do you have to yeah
my question pertains to your time before
you started college because as I
understand before you had entered
college you were very much just a
pianist and you focused on melt or
melodic writing and whatnot and I'm sure
it was around that point that you
realized that you have to do mixing and
mastering to enter that career I just
wanted to know what did you do to help
yourself catch up on those things yeah
so I remember when I applied to the
Royal Academy of Music I remember my my
portfolio I'm still not sure why they
accepted me because there was there was
literally one piece of orchestral music
in there and it was it was barely an
orchestral piece of music
it was mostly piano stuff but the reason
they picked me is because of my melodic
writing and they said everything else he
can learn and so all of the
orchestration stuff we had orchestration
classes at the academy but what I really
learned while I was there was from going
to the practice rooms and harassing the
students and telling me to teach them
about their instrument and you know they
were more than willing to do so because
it broke up the monotony of their
practice so that's rolling the
orchestration in terms of mixing and
mastering that comes back to the
electronic music actually so and it also
comes down to listening I listen to a
lot of music and by listening I don't
mean having it on in the car or having
on the kitchen while you cook or just
hanging on in the background that's
passive listening I think passive
listening is terrible
I especially if you're a composer you
should be actively listening to you know
at least one album of music a week if
not more and train to break you know try
and break down a track and try and learn
what makes it good or not what makes it
good but why do you like it try and
break it down and that's honestly how I
learnt mixing and mastering I would take
eight
crack by someone else bring it into my
software and try and recreate it and I
would just try and get as close as I can
and by that you're not only you're
learning all kinds of technical skills
but you're also training your ears as
well and training your ears is a
lifetime study so there's no excuse to
ever stop doing that so you're always
constantly learning so I'm always trying
to constantly actively listen given
advice about the pitching process like
do you make new tracks though or do you
use stuff you've done in the past or it
depends on how much time I have some
pitches they're just like yeah can you
put something together in two days then
I'll try to post something one thing
original and then you know try and find
similar tracks in my library like it but
if I have a week or two and I'll usually
trying to a minimum of three tracks but
a lot of pictures in games now actually
have very specific briefs which actually
is really helpful I'm usually the one an
ambient piece of music the one a combat
piece of music and they want to show
they want to see how you're going to
transition from one to the other and
often they'll want like a high concept
track like nothing that really ties into
game play but like what do you write a
piece of music that you feel this game
represents based on what we've told you
there's no real secret to pitching other
than whatever you are pitching don't
cheat on it make sure it sounds like the
final product that's probably going to
cost you money
and that part sucks I've I had a run in
26 3 2016 through 2017 where I lost four
pitches in a row and spent a decent
amount of money on it but at the end of
the day even if you lose the pitch
you've still got a finished piece of
music that is really high-quality that
you could probably use somewhere else or
sell somewhere else so there's no real
loss to it it just can hurt at the time
if you if you lose
but it's the Nate it composes far far
more famous than me lose pictures all
the time
and for far far bigger than me for the
lose pictures all the times to do like
it's normal to lose pictures you will
lose far more than you win so my only
advice on pitching is just to do the
absolute best job you possibly can with
the resources that you have this is the
final question gosh massive pressure
thank you very much
we regards to the girl with the pitching
yes as I write mainly consulate music
but also a pitch for us I'm used to
pitching for ads but I very much like
the idea of getting into games where
where do I get to pitch where do you get
to pitch
yes or how do I find outs I mean in my
case my agent just sends me the stuff
and I respond but but generally if you
are looking for opportunities to pitch
you kind of need to go to the places
where people are making games so if if I
want to get more work I'm going to go to
the Game Developers Conference I'm going
to go to pax I'm going to go to e3 I'm
going to go to games calm I'm going to
go to develop there's there are so many
places where game developers are
congregating but I'm not going to
aggressively advertise myself so I'm
just gonna make myself known and appear
on the scene and if people you know if
if I build up a rapport with someone
then that's great but I try not to I try
not to force myself on to people because
ultimately I want people to discover me
through my work and that's a couple of
the pictures I've gotten have been
solely because people played Orion
thought oh I wonder if we could hire the
Ori composer on our project maybe he's a
good fit let's have him try something so
in many ways I think though the way to
get more pictures is to do more work but
of course to do more work you might need
to win more pictures so it's kind of a
chicken and egg thing but you could
there's or you don't need the you don't
need necessarily to have a pitch to
write more music I was saying earlier to
some
some composers there is no excuse for a
composer not to be writing music every
single day of their life if they if they
want to the only person stopping me from
writing music is myself even if I'm not
scoring a game or scoring a film there
is always someone that needs music
somewhere so I should be writing
something every single day if you're
writing something every single day that
means you have something new to put out
into the world which potentially someone
could listen to did you ever go down the
library route to any time have you ever
I still am going down the library Mia's
library music fruit and yeah I've been
building building library music a
catalog for five or six years now which
is making life a lot easier but it's
something you really have to persevere
with you you can't kind of do it
half-heartedly because you need a huge
amount of music to make a decent amount
of income to have library music make a
significant difference but that's just
another revenue stream for composer most
of us like to sit in our ivory towers
and think yes I'll score games the rest
of my life but what are you gonna do
when no game comes along for a year or
two yeah kind of got to do something
else
fortunately library music as it is a
good I have Anu for that so I'd like to
say a massive thank you for guys for
coming today
I also like say a massive thank you for
you guys coming along to support game
events at basta
once again a huge thank you to the buff
der partners Activision Blizzard EA play
fusion Sega Tencent games and Ubisoft
and finally just a bit of a promotion
for the BAFTA crew games earlier today
BAFTA crew games got to meet with Gareth
for a private roundtable event so if any
of you would like to know more about
BAFTA crew games if you visit guru
bastard org forward slash opportunities
to find out more I'd say getting there
quick because the deadline for this lot
of applications closes on the 23rd of
April so with that with that that we
should thank Adele for doing a great job
posting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]